new games get announced all the time but
some of them seem to fade into the
shadows
as time goes on with few updates or no
official cancellations
these forgotten games will just leave
you wondering where they stand
if you're not subbed and you want to
yearn for new details together why not
like this video
and subscribe alright let's go
announced at e3 2017 skull and bones is
a pirate themed
open world action game that seems to be
a bit of an evolution to the ship combat
scene in assassin's creed 4 black flag
aside from single player and multiplayer
game trailers we haven't seen much
else since e3 2018 and e3 2019
was skipped entirely despite the silence
the game still seems to be in motion
though a tv adaptation with atlas
entertainment for skull and bones was
even announced last year which means all
signs do point to an eventual release
ubisoft says it remains committed to
launching the game and supporting it for
years to come
with more details coming in 2021 you
might remember a little gem called
street fighter x tekken which was a
crossover that brought some 3d tekken
favorites over to the 2d
street fighter realm and featured
interesting crew battles now if you
reverse that concept you'll get tekken x
street fighter which was supposed to be
the 3d follow-up version of
the crossover and was announced way back
in 2010
for ps3 and xbox 360. it wasn't until
2016 that the game's producer katsuhiro
hirata announced that the game was no
longer in development
around that same time when we reached
out to publisher bandai namco it stated
it was waiting for the right time to
release tekken x street fighter but was
focusing on dlc for tekken 7.
one of those dlc characters ended up
being akuma from street fighter 4
focus attack and all which showed that
the concept was being worked on to some
extent
what makes things more interesting is
that nearly a decade later harada turned
to twitter and used the twitter poll to
see the fans were still
waiting on the game so even if it's
still on hold it's definitely still on
harada's mind
hollow knight silk song is the sequel to
hollow knight where you play as hornet
hollow knight's secondary protagonist
picking up from one of the original
game's five endings silicon will take
you through a unique world
similar to its predecessor as we've seen
from the game's demo at e3 2019
fans are eagerly waiting for a release
date but the game's developer team
cherry made it clear that it will only
release the game when it's ready
and when it matches the quality and
scale of hollow knight with team cherry
creating
never-before-seen areas that seem bigger
than anything they've made before
remaining tight-lipped about the new
gameplay mechanics and providing
new experiences through hornet like
dialogue there will be a lot to discover
in silksong when it's finally here
deep down is now in its fifth year on
our missing games list after being
officially revealed in 2013
a long seven years ago there were
trailers and reveals for capcom's ps4
exclusive dungeon crawler being released
all the way up to 2015 with big news
like the game being free to play and the
announcement of an open beta
that never arrived since then the entire
team originally developing deep down
have moved on from the project which
might sound bad but
capcom did renew the trademark for deep
down in 2017
which starts to raise questions about
the game being on hiatus for the next
gen to fulfill its intended vision
it's looking bleak but yoshinori ono
previously of capcom
said that if the trademark is renewed
then there's still a chance
although trademark filings don't
necessarily signal a company's intent to
use them
let's see if that will be the case
before or after we hit the decade mark
inspired by favorites like the legend of
zelda and the works of studio ghibli
balto is a hand-drawn action adventure
rpg that was supposed to be a timed
exclusive for the nintendo switch for
the summer of 2020.
baldo was delayed indefinitely in
september
but there were signs of life from the
game as recently as this past october
via twitter but
no word on an official release date
baldo is said to be a puzzle and dungeon
game at its core but has plenty of
secrets inside
a project 15 years in the works is
hopefully
in its final stretch and taking
advantage of today's technology
as the idea behind baldo originated back
in the game boy advance era
ever since the trailer's release i've
been excited to jump into this magical
miyazaki-like world and learn more about
baldo and its unique looking cast of
characters but for now
we'll just have to wait call me
optimistic but with
nextgen officially in our hands i'm
remaining hopeful that it will improve
the chances of seeing some of these
titles
make their way to us soon there are even
more games that are mia
and if you want to see our full list
then make sure you check out
[Music]
gamespot.com